entre las opciones de tratamiento para
el cáncer se encuentran las siguientes
cirugía radioterapia quimioterapia y
terapia hormonal
existen varias opciones quirúrgicas
según la gravedad del cáncer en una
tumorectomía se extrae el tumor y una
pequeña cantidad del tejido circundante
una mastectomía implica la extracción de
todo el seno y sus tejidos la extracción
de ganglios linfáticos se realiza
típicamente junto con la tumorectomía y
la mastectomía
en este caso el cirujano extraerá los
ganglios linfáticos de la axila
si existe algún motivo para creer que el
cáncer se ha diseminado más allá del
seno una mastectomía profiláctica es una
cirugía preventiva para las mujeres de
alto riesgo en la que se extrae todo el
seno para disminuir el riesgo del cáncer
de seno
en la radioterapia se utilizan rayos x
de alta energía u otros tipos de
radiación para eliminar las células
cancerígenas o evitar que crezcan
la radioterapia interna se puede
utilizar para tratar el cáncer desde el
interior del cuerpo con agujas alambres
o catéteres la quimioterapia es un
tratamiento que utiliza fármacos para
detener el crecimiento de las células
cancerígenas eliminando las o evitando
su división celular una vez que los
fármacos entran en el flujo sanguíneo se
desplazan y llegan a las células
cancerígenas de todo el cuerpo
algunos tipos de cánceres de seno
necesitan hormonas para crecer y
diseminarse
la terapia hormonal evita que las
células cancerígenas reciban las
hormonas naturales que necesitan los
análisis pueden demostrar si su tumor de
seno tiene esos receptores y si es una
buena opción de tratamiento